Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between US and UK Papa John's.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, our sizes start at small.
Ours is 9.5 inches across
with a surface area of 71 square inches.
Joe Avella: Our small pizza
comes in at 10 inches,
which is 78.5 square inches of pizza.
Harry: Next up, we have our medium pizza.
It's 11.5 inches across
with a surface area of
103.8 square inches.
Joe: Our large, 14 inches,
which is 153.9 square inches.
Harry: Finally, for some
reason, we skip extra large
and go straight to extra-extra large.
This one's 15.5 inches across
with a surface area of
188.7 square inches.
Joe: We didn't skip the extra large.
16 inches, right here.
That's 201 square izzos of pizzo.
Our extra large is bigger
than your extra-extra large!
In your face, Harry.
Harry: In the UK, a small cheese pizza
will cost you £11.99,
which is around $15.54.
That's a price per square
inch of 21.8 cents.
Joe: Small in the US, $9.49,
which is about 12 cents per square inch.
I know I got a small, but
apparently they're also
doing small peppers with the small pizzas.
Look how small this is.
Skimping on the peppers, eh, Papa?
Harry: An XXL cheese pizza in the UK
will cost you around $23.32,
which is a price of 12.3
cents per square inch.
Joe: USA's extra large, $15.49.
That cannot be right.
Sprinkle a little math on that.
That's 7.7 cents per square inch.
That is so cheap.
Harry: So, what can we
take away from this?
Well, in both countries,
the more pizza you buy,
the cheaper it gets.
In the US, the price per
square inch of a small
is 55% more than an extra large.
And in the UK, it shoots
up to a huge 77% more.
Joe: I mean, it makes sense, right?
I mean, that's how they get you.
They pretty much are tricking
you into getting more pizza
'cause it's cheaper per square inch.
So you're going, "Oh, I'll just get
the extra large instead."
And then a year later you're fat. [laughs]
Whoops. It was such a good deal!
Harry: It is worth
noting that painful price
is kind of rare in the UK.
We got, like, a 40%-off deal
because we spent a
certain amount of money.
Basically, if you're paying
full price in the UK,
you're really not getting
the best value for money.
Joe: I'm on their website right now,
and it looks like, yeah,
they have endless "specials," or deals,
for pretty much every
combination you want to get.
Large one-topping pizza, any
two sides, two large pizzas.
I'm assuming what Papa John's does
is have all types of deals
and codes and promotions
that whatever you get
when you order Papa John's
was probably a deal for you.
So you probably are
never paying full price.
Harry: In the UK, an
extra-extra-large cheese pizza
is cut into 12 slices.
Each of these 12 slices is 268 calories,
which brings the total to
a whopping 3,218 calories.
Joe: In the US, our extra
large is cut into 10 slices.
That means each slice
has roughly 300 calories.
And there is no possible way
you're eating this
pizza without the sauce.
[hands slapping]
Whew!
Harry: What about the most
calorific thing on the menu?
In the UK, it's a sausage
and pepperoni pizza.
Now, for an XXL version of this pizza,
each slice is 355 calories.
That brings the total to 4,260 calories.
Joe: In the US, if you're
going for most calories,
it's a tie between the meats pizza
and the pepperoni, sausage,
and three cheese pizza.
This used to be John's favorite.
They changed the name.
They took his name off of it when he left.
I wonder what happened to that guy?
[laughs]
Each pizza is roughly
410 calories per slice.
And since it's 10 slices per pizza,
that is a whopping 4,100
calories per pizza.
Ha!
Harry: So, despite the average pizza sizes
being smaller in the UK,
the pizzas themselves are
actually more calorific.
Who knew?
Now, despite Papa John's motto being,
"Better ingredients. Better pizza,"
they don't actually make their full
ingredients list available in the UK.
We did reach out to them to see if they'd
make an exception for us, but
at the time of shooting this,
unfortunately we haven't heard back.
Joe: Now, because we can't
get the UK Papa John's
ingredients list, we're gonna tweak
this section a little bit.
We're gonna compare the
US Papa John's ingredients
to another very popular
fast-food pizza chain, Domino's.
Let's get Domino's dough
ingredients on the screen.
[bell dings]
OK. Now let's compare that
with the Papa John's US dough ingredients.
Unbleached enriched wheat
flour, water, sugar,
soybean oil, salt, yeast.
And that's it.
How hilarious is that?
See? Doesn't need to be
a whole chemistry lab.
OK. I gotta give Papa John's
props. That's really great.
They say fresher ingredients,
and they mean it. I like that.
Harry: Here is everything
you can only find
on the menu at a UK Papa John's.
Joe: And these are all
the USA-exclusive items
you can get at Papa John's.
Harry: Let's start with the pizzas.
So, in front of me, I have three pizzas.
And across these three,
we've covered pretty much
all of the items you can
only find on the menu
at a UK Papa John's.
So, what I have right in front of me here
is a pizza with a butternut squash base.
Now, this is on the menu as
a gluten-free alternative
to traditional doughs.
Then the pizzas outside
of that, as you can see,
have a stuffed crust, which
is just the classic crust
but then folded over and
filled with a kind of cheesy,
garlicky mix, which is
really, really good.
Joe: This right here is a pizza consisting
of only the toppings and crust
that you can get in the US.
We have the Parmesan cheese,
garlic-crusted crust.
Crusted crust!
Harry: Now, from there, you can also
customize the base sauce.
So instead of the tomato
sauce on this one,
we have an amarillo chili sauce.
Joe: I was not aware
of this until recently,
but apparently at a Papa
John's in the United States,
you can substitute the
tomato sauce for ranch.
And I did exactly that,
because there's nothing
more American then ranch dressing.
Harry: Papa John's in the UK
actually offers quite a few
vegetarian and vegan options.
For example, again, on this pizza,
instead of the classic
mozzarella-blend cheese,
we have a vegan "sheese,"
which is a cheese alternative
that's friendly for vegans.
So, in the UK, you can top
your pizza with anchovies,
with tuna, with tandoori
chicken, with spicy beef,
and also some fake meat alternatives
such as vegan pepperoni
and also a vegan sausage.
Finally, we have a couple
of vegetarian toppings.
For example, on this pizza,
we have some red chilies,
and on this pizza, we have
feta cheese and sweet corn.
Joe: Cheese. We did do the Parmesan Romano
and the three-cheese
blend, which is provolone,
fontana, fontania, fontawhatever,
and Asiago cheeses.
Salami, Canadian bacon,
the Philly cheesesteak stuff,
spinach, and also, of
course, banana peppers.
I don't know what it
is with banana peppers.
They're suddenly on everything.
I don't get it.
All right. [sighs]
Here we go. All right.
Positive mental attitude. PMA.
I'm about to have the USA Only.
No, I do not like that.
I'll admit it's growing on me.
I wouldn't pick the ranch sauce.
I would stick with tomato.
But yeah, not bad.
Harry: Oh, God.
That's not good. [laughs]
Oh, man. Don't, don't order this.
Don't order the UK-only pizza.
Moving swiftly on from the UK-only pizza,
here are some sides you
can only find on the menu
at a UK Papa John's.
We've got some vegan cauliflower wings.
It's basically just small
pieces of cauliflower
that are breaded and fried,
and then you can kind of dip
them in a sauce of your choice.
Just a nice chicken-wing
alternative for vegetarians.
Here we've got some chicken poppers.
Now, I think these are
available in the US,
but the one that's exclusive to the UK
is the tandoori chicken spice one,
which is just pieces of chicken
breaded and fried with
an Indian spice blend.
Here we've got some tater tots,
which I'm surprised you
guys can't get in the US,
'cause these aren't
really a thing in the UK,
but here we can get tater tots.
You can get them with
cheese like we have here,
or you can also get them
with cheese and bacon.
And then finally, again,
surprising you don't have these in the US,
these are some jalapeño poppers.
Just kind of mini jalapeños, breaded,
fried, with some cheese inside.
Now, I'm super excited to try these.
These are Marmite Scrolls.
What it is, is kind of
pieces of dough rolled up
with some cheese and some
Marmite in the middle of them.
Now, Joe, if you've never had Marmite,
it sounds gross, 'cause it's actually --
Joe: Harry, yes, I actually
in fact have had Marmite.
It was a while ago in college.
I lived briefly with a British
guy, he had a jar of it.
I did try it once.
I don't remember exactly how it tasted,
but I do recall comparing
it to the taste of vomit.
So suffice to say,
I'm in the "not fan of Marmite" category.
So far, the Papa John's
sides game is pretty strong.
Now, for wings,
we have a honey chipotle wing sauce.
Garlic knots.
Oh, man!
Ugh!
Dude, this thing is
drenched in their butter.
I'm confused by this next USA-only thing.
It is called a Papadia.
I mean, it's a calzone,
but for some reason
they're calling it a Papadia,
which I assume is a playoff of quesadilla.
Yeah, look, it's just a pizza
that they cut and folded over, right?
Moving on! These look good.
[hands slapping]
These look right up my alley.
These are the jalapeño
popper rolls and ranch.
Forgot, we also got breadsticks!
Here are some US-exclusive sauces:
spicy garlic,
ranch, of course,
honey mustard,
blue cheese,
regular cheese.
And you can also get, big surprise,
a side of banana peppers.
Also, side of jalapeños.
And I was as surprised as anyone to see,
also in the US, you can get these.
Side of anchovies.
[bell dings]
Harry: Finally, for those
of you with a sweet tooth,
Papa John's in the UK has
a few exclusive desserts.
Sides, we have some chocolate
scrolls on my right,
and some cinnamon scrolls on my left.
And then finally we have
some Ben and Jerry's.
Papa John's in the UK is kind of like
a Ben and Jerry's licensed
vendor, which is quite cool.
And then also we can get
some milkshakes here,
which are a brand called F'real,
and they're not bad.
Joe: And for dessert, the one thing we got
that you don't have, UK,
cinnamon pull-aparts.
Again, apologies. It's
been sitting for a while.
Dude,
yes to these.
I guess I'm not supposed to,
I mean, I don't have to try everything,
but I'm kind of curious, right?
Oh, boy.